all right it's the afternoon session
thank you everybody for staying around
um we've got two talks coming up i'm
very excited for we've got
two of the most intelligent
people that i'm aware of um mark of the
va is going to go first he's talking
about uh what says in his title um i'm
excited i have a little bit of work with
this and he's promising me a new proof
on a conjecture that i've never seen
before so stay tuned uh so i i will not
do the proof so
[Laughter]
uh thank you for the introduction
so yes so so today i will talk about uh
two things so a first one is a joint
work with ellie so i guess you will
understand what they say and uh and
xavier
which is that nature correlations are
genuinely multi-party non-local so i
will explain what it means it's kind of
a stronger version of
belmont locality
and then
with this i will be able to introduce
what i call the most uh general
causal theory in a causal structure so
you know that if you take a causal
structure you can define what are the
correlations which can be obtained from
classical theory from quantum theory and
here somehow we'll try to define the
most general set one can imagine
okay so let me start first with an
overview of what i will prove so in
quantum theory you know that if i have
three parties sharing some quantum state
i have a very concrete formalism which
tell me what are the potential
probability distribution of some outputs
given some inputs which can be obtained
in that case
and then the goal here will be to try
whether there to try to see whether
there
does not exist a new theory
which would be able to explain those
probability distribution
and i will not take any theory i will
restrict my theory to be like this so
it's a theory in which the party have
access to classical shareholders so
there is a classical process going to
the three-party measurement measurement
boxes
plus
any so what i call exotic post-quantum
bipartite state so this just has to be
understood as any futuristic
generalization of antagon so any theory
describing bipartite sources in let's
say 200 years
uh so it will be a generalization of all
the theories which have been introduced
to generalize quantum theory so for
instance no synonym boxes or generalized
probabilistic theories etc
and what i will
do is to find a very concrete quantum
state and very concrete way to measure
that state such that i obtain a
probability distribution and i will show
that this very specific probability
distribution cannot be obtained in any
such uh futuristic theory
um so the correlation i will obtain i
will call it genuinely tripartite
non-local because first it is non-local
correlation i cannot obtain them from a
classical process but i also cannot
obtain them from a classical process
plus bipartite
futuristic
resources
so actually we also have a
generalization for this for any number
of parties so if now you create a theory
in which you have those weird sources
going to end parties at most n parties i
also have a concrete experiment with n
plus one part is sharing a quantum state
which cannot be explained
so
with this also i will be able to define
and characterize what i call the most
general causal theory of
correlations so before going more into
the detail i just want to tell you that
this is just actually a generalization
of bell theorem so
in bell theorem you know that if two
parties are sharing a quantum source
you can
well choose the quantum source and the
way to measure it such that you will
obtain a probability distribution which
obtains two square root of two for the
chsh inequality
and then
uh this two squared of two experiment
cannot be explained by classical
randomness
so i guess it is clear for all of you
even if you don't know how to describe
this modern source
you can accept it
and then
i can do the same with three parties so
for instance i have the jetsetter min
experiment which cannot be obtained in
this network but actually if i have
three parties and if my only goal is to
rule out
the fact that i can explain everything
with classical randomness i could as
well just ignore charlie and just
perform a standard bell uh chsh
experiment between alice and bob and
this is already enough to rule out
classical randomness so having three
parties is not so
useful right
but what i will do here is a
generalization of both this ghz and this
chsh so i should say that yeah i will
say it now so actually this glz mermaid
experiment i can also find a violation
of it with this network so now my goal
is to find some correlation which allow
me to rule out uh this kind of
explanation so obviously with this kind
of explanation i can explain chsh
between 80 and actually i can also
explain this jz mermaid experiment uh
just because this is a generalization of
quantum theory so it obviously includes
quantum sources
so i will obtain a probability
distribution which cannot be obtained
like this and which is a genuine trap no
local correlation
okay so
for now i was not really concrete
because i told you i will consider any
exotic generalization of quantum theory
but i didn't tell you what it means so i
will be a bit more formal now and
explain to you what are the constraints
i put over that theory and as you will
see it's very weak so i i'm quite sure
every body will
by the fact that any theory should
satisfy those constraints
so first if you have uh some causal
structure with classical variables uh
it's uh quite clear how to describe this
so there is a
formalism in which we say that we will
attribute some hidden random process for
each of these latin variables and then
we can integrate over all the possible
values taken by this variable and we
have some
if it is connected to alice for instance
alice will output something depending on
some input for instance plus the long
dash is connected to
then if i have quantum sources in my
network structure there is also a very
concrete formalism in which i describe
the source with the density matrix and i
have the bond rule etc so it's not so
important to understand this i'm just
saying that there is a concrete formal
formalism and formula to tell you what
are the accessible probability
distribution
but now what about these weird exotic
sources how to define what i can do with
them
so this is
what i want to do now so actually i will
just
put two assumptions over two sources
the first one is that those sources
should be causal so causality for me
will be something which includes
generalizes uh no signaling so
it will become clearer what i mean
exactly by causality for now i keep it
at a high level
and i will have a second assumption
which i call a device replication
so by device replication i just mean
that if i have somewhere in my causal
network uh some some source
e for instance then um allow it to
create a duncan experiment a thought
experiment using iid copies of that
source so using independent but
identical sources so this is something
which is very standard in uh classical
theory if you have for instance the
latent variable which is a biased coin
then it's quite clear that you can
create a new bias coin which will have
the exactly the same bias as the first
one but which will be completely
independent
okay
and then for quantum sources it's
exactly the same if you have a laser
emitting some state then you can create
a second laser which works the same
which emits the same state not i mean an
identical state right which is
independent from the first one
and uh well you can create a new
experiment out of those two lasers
and here this is what i assume if i have
an exotic source which will be created
in 200 years then actually it will be
possible to create two such sources such
that the two are independent so i'm not
at all describing how it works i'm just
saying that i can make independent
copies
so these axioms
are satisfied by quantum number called
boxes uh
gpts all the theories which were
introduced to generalize quantum theory
and actually they were already
introduced in several papers for
instance called no signaling and
independence in some papers
okay so now out of these two definition
two constraint i put on my theory so
causality and device replication i will
first show you that
three parties cannot share a random bit
in the triangle scenario so this was
already proven by ellie in his inflation
paper also in this paper
and i will redo the proof to really
concretely show you how
one can
show non-trivial stuff
just using causality and device
replication so the goal here is to
consider this probability distribution
which is just so with one half
probability the three parts will output
zero with one half they will output one
so just a shared run a bit
and i will show you so obviously this
can be done in this network structure
but i will show you that it cannot
be done in this network structure
whatever the theory i use to describe
those weird exotic sources as long as
they satisfy causality and device
replication
and i will do a proof by contradiction
and actually it uses the inflation
technique
so how is this proof so i just changed
the way i i draw stuff but it's the same
so i do approve by contradiction i
assume that i can do this probability
distribution in this triangle network
and i will first use device replication
to create independent duplicates of the
element of the network so again
this i can
this source e i can understand it maybe
as a futuristic
biased coin right in some futuristic
theory and i just create two such coins
and i do the same for source f for
source g and also for the measurement
devices
and now i replace those measurement
devices in a new network which is called
so an inflated network so it's very
closely related to what ali was doing
it's the same actually and i consider
this new network and then when i did
this network something which is very
important is that i i was really careful
at uh keeping the type of the system so
you see this source e
is something which is going to a and
this source g is something which is
going to a and a is a measurement box
which is uh somehow eating a signal from
e and eating a signal from g to output
something but if i was sending some f to
a
maybe a would not know how to measure
this because maybe this is a futuristic
coin a futuristic photon a futuristic
dice a does not know what to do with the
futuristic photon right so when i do
inflation i should
keep the same tags the same type of
systems but this inflation is allowed
and it should be associated to some
probability distribution
and uh then i have some compatibility
between this probability distribution
and the probability distribution i had
in my triangle so this is actually a
definition of what i call causality
so in causality a first action is that
for instance if i look at the marginal
of q over alice and bob
so
like this i should see the same as the
marginal of q of p over aliso and bob in
this triangle structure and why is it
the case it's just because i have
exactly the same causal structure with
exactly the same elements so if i have
two phenomenon which are composed of the
same
elements then i should see the same
so this implies in particular as a is
always equal to b in this triangle that
a is always equal to b in q
okay and the same between b and c for
the same reason
so this is my first assumption of
causality if i have the same structure i
see the same phenomenon
and then i have a second assumption
which is a compatibility condition of q
with the network itself the integrated
network itself and you see if i only
isolate a and c and just look at the
marginal over a and c
i have two phenomenon a and c which have
no common past no common event to
explain them so causality in that case
tells me that i should have
factorization so this is the second
content of my causality action and there
is no more so i when i say my source
should be causal means that i can do
this first deduction and do this second
deduction
and then
from those two deductions i have a
contradiction so first from i
as a is always equal to b and b is
always equal to c i can deduce that a is
always equal to c in this network
and then from 2i
as a and c are independent
and then also a should be distributed as
in this triangle network i have that a
the probability that a is equal to c
should be one half so i have a
contradiction so i have proven that a
shared random bit cannot be obtained in
the triangle whatever the theory i
consider even in 200 years uh with the
theory it will not be able
nobody will be able to do that
okay
so this was a sort of a warm-up just to
explain the idea behind and now i will
go to my problem so my problem is to
find a quantum experiment which cannot
be explained with this more involved
structure in which i also have access to
shared randomness
um so okay this is quantum theory so i
will quickly give the quantum
protocol but i know that not everybody
no quantum theory so i will try to also
give the very high level ids behind
so i use this quantum protocol and
actually if you look more precisely
inside this
quantum protocol so it's bad because you
don't see
a part of it so maybe you can look on
undo screen it will be easier
so
you see on the screen that
i have a first part of the protocol
which corresponds to input 0 for alice
and charlie
and
2 for
bob which corresponds to measuring sigma
z over the g at z state and this just
tells me that the party will output a
shared random bit
so you can do quantum computation you
will see that for input 0 for alice and
2 for bob and 0 for charlie you have a
shared random bit which means that this
quantity is always equal to 2. so this
check that alice and bob have the same
input output and this check that bob and
charlie have the same output it's true
because they output the shared run of it
they obtain two
and then i have uh yes so
outputting such a shared run a bit
obviously cannot be done in this network
causal structure this is what i just
proved but can be done in this network
structure and then i have a second part
of the proof which is the following
which corresponds to so it's input one
for charlie who is measuring sigma z and
then in quantum mechanics when you look
at what's going on it projects the state
between alice and bob in the five plus
and then actually if you look at the
game for alice and bob input one it
corresponds to a standard chsh game so
for the other input of charlie i have a
standard chsh violation between alice
and bob
so for the second half of my probability
distribution i have a game which is the
standard chsh game steered by alice by
charlie so it depends on charlie input
and output
and then
this second game obviously i can win it
in this kind of scenario because i have
access to some
non local sources like this but as it is
a non-local game i have a score two
sport or two as some chsh i cannot do it
in this
kind of scenario
and then actually this is enough because
i will combine the two game just looking
at the global score which is this
expression
so the four is really coming from our
proof i won't explain it and then what
we were able to prove
was that it was not possible to obtain
such a big score with this kind of
structure you are limited by 10.
and the idea behind is the proof by
inflation so we start from so this is
the same triangle structure with the
local source right we start from this
structure and we perform this inflation
half of the inflation is looking at the
bell game the second half is looking at
the same game and what is really
important is that alice
for input zero
she is
playing both the bell game because her
input 0 is considered in the score for
the bell game and also the same game
because her input 0 is also taken into
account into the same game and the
problem is that as alice when you have
input 0 you don't know if you are
playing the bell game or if you are
playing the same game because this is
decided by the input of the other
parties
and in order to have a maximum score at
the bell game you would need to use the
non-local source of randomness so that
source and in order to maximally win the
same game you should use the dice but
you don't know which one to use and you
have a problem and you cannot obtain a
maximum score so this is the
basic idea behind our proof
okay so this we could generalize to more
parties so if now you take four parties
and you have those exotic but now
tripartite sources and you add classical
shared randomness between the four
parties we have a concrete quantum
experiment which can rule out this kind
of explanation so it's a direct
generalization to more parties and we
can really do it for any n way sources
so we also perform some experiment and
other groups perform experiments about
this
so i don't know how much
time i have left
well okay i go
okay so now
i will use this to tell you actually uh
that what we have done is
also a definition of what i call the
most general causal theory of
correlations in causal structures so why
do i mean by this
so
i will first do it without shared
randomness uh to to make something
simple uh at first
so it is just the largest theory i can
imagine which is satisfying my two
actions of device replication of
causality and how does it go so so first
i can really define this so for the
triangle network structure for any
network like this in which i have some
hidden sources resist by some uh like
visible nodes which perform some
measurement about it but actually i
could also define it in any
dag directed at cyclic graph with
several latent sources and observed
nodes with a very complex structure i
can also make this kind of definition
and the definition is the following so i
will just do it for the triangle for
simplicity but really you can always
define it for any dag
so you will say that the probability
distribution is feasible in the triangle
with these exotic post quantum sources
if and only if
for any imaginable inflation of the
triangle so when you inflate the
triangle you can make two copies of each
element in which case you can create
this hexagon inflation we have already
created you could also decide to make
three copies in which case you could
create this larger inflation with nine
parties and actually you could have nine
parties 12 parties 15 parties etc up to
infinity cyclic like this
and then you will say that p is feasible
in the triangle if and only for each
such inflation you can find a
probability distribution which is
compatible with both p
and the inflation so it's exactly what
we have done with the random bits but in
a systematic way so for instance for p
to be feasible in the triangle i should
find a q
which is giving a probability
distribution for this network of nine
parties such that if i take two
consecutive parties so for instance
alice and bob it should coincide the
marginal with the marginal of p there
and now if i take uh for instance a b c
and b prime c prime second
it should factorize because these two
group of parties have no source in
common so according to causality they
should factorize and then the last
condition is that this queue should be
symmetric by permutation if i exchange
the rule of a with a prime with a second
and i do the same for b and for c then
it should be the same because i just
have a clear cyclic permutation
so i can define a theory like this the
theory is just the set of probability
which satisfy
the existence of a queue which is
compatible with p and the network for
each inflation
so
this is a a nice way to define this but
it's quite
weird because in classical theory when
you define the feasible probability
distribution you have a concrete
formally formalism and formula with an
integral over the lambda you put your d
lambda you have something really
concrete to describe the probability
distribution in quantum theory it's the
same so you have density matrices you
have the trace rule etc so it's also
something very concrete how to compute
this here it's quite different because i
come up with a definition
from the outside somehow i'm just
rejecting my probability distribution so
the a very important question is do can
i also define a concrete model a
concrete formalism
to tell me how this probability
distribution was obtained with a
concrete form formula to describe my
sources my measurement boxes etc and
that actually it exists so this is a
work in preparation but it exists
through this
opt models which were introduced for
instance in this paper in this book
and we can really each time p is
feasible according to this definition
with inflation we can really give an
operational probabilistic model or a dpt
with
a concrete
description of these sources and these
states which obtain p
okay so this was without classical
randomness so now let me go a bit
further and try to define again
the most general causal theory of
correlations when the party have access
to shared randomness like this
so this is now what i was
considering
before and actually there are two
potential definitions there is a first
one which is just saying that when i
have classical information
uh i can think at it as something which
i can control so of course when you when
this is the dag explaining your
probability distribution you cannot
maybe control the sources but you can
create a gathering can experiment in
which you will be able to
fix the value of
this
random variable lambda to some lambda
zero and just see what is going on so
classical information you you can
imagine this right you can imagine that
in principle you could control this
lambda source
and then if you do this you will observe
a p
post selected or a lambda zero right
because now lambda is always delivering
the signal lambda zero
and then it means that as now p lambda 0
is obtained in this network with a
source of randomness which is always
taking the same value
actually this p lambda 0 is obtained in
this triangle network without shared
randomness because the shared randomness
is fixed right so this p lambda zero
should be compatible with my inflation
so i just can use my previous definition
without uh schedule unless to explain
how to define the feasible
p lambda zero okay so i do this and i
can define p lambda zero and then i come
back to this and i say okay but actually
i'm not able to fix this lambda to
lambda zero so how should i describe p
well p is just what you obtain when you
integrate over all potential value of
lambda
the corresponding distribution so i will
just say that p
is feasible in this network if and only
if there exists a random variable lambda
a hidden variable lambda and some p
lambda 0 such that p which are
compatible with all my inflation such
that p writes like this
okay
and this is the first definition and
there is a second possible definition
in which now
i will only remember the fact that a
classical source of randomness i can
duplicate the output i can do some
fanout inflation so this is what ellie
explained this morning when i have a
classical source of randomness i can
clone the output and send it to more
parties so if i have this inflation for
instance i could create a lambda and a
lambda prime and send lambda to abc
lambda prime to a prime b prime c prime
but actually as lambda is a classical
source of randomness i can as well
duplicate the signal sent by the source
lambda and send it to everyone and
create this new kind of inflation
right
and then
i will just say that
my p
to be feasible in this network should be
compatible with all the imaginable
inflation i can create doing such kind
of inflation in which i will have a
mixed
inflation with a non-fan-out inflation
of my exotic sources and the fan-out
inflation of my classical sources
so for instance i would also do this
right
and then uh so i have two alternative
definitions so this is quite annoying
right so it's quite easy to show that
definition one is included in definition
two
well i i don't do it but it's very
trivial actually
but then uh are they equal so actually
this is the in preparation work and i
think we have a proof but again it's to
be confirmed because it's quite recent
but the two definitions are equal
and i think physically this is very
important because this indicates that in
this context
classical
sources is equal to clonable sources so
my first definition
is
about what i call classical information
classical information is something i can
control fix the value see what happens
and integrate back over it
and cloneable inflation information is
coming from that definition it's
information which i can clone which i
can duplicate and send to many parties
and then it's not so clear that
classical equal clonable i have this
inclusion which is trivial right but
i could have maybe other kind of
information theory which allow me for
cloning but which is not classical so
this proof shows that in this context
classical is equal to clonable
okay so uh i'm done so to conclude so i
have proved that nature correlations are
generally multipatient non-local so if
you have a theory in which you say that
you will generalize n-partite antagon to
some exotic n-partite post
entanglement
it's not enough you need to to do this
for any n right
there are some experiments which uh
checked this and then i gave a
definition of what i call the most
general
theory of correlations in a causal
structure without and with shared
randomness
this corresponds to a concrete formalism
so i can find a concrete model
and in this context classical
information is equal to clonable
information
and then uh so
where to go with this so i i think there
is a first natural question which is to
ask for instance about this kind of
structure so
again now i have two sources of
classical randomness plus my exotic
sources right so in this kind of
scenario i could also come up with the
same definition one definition two one
being about classical information the
second about clonable information are
they the same
so it's a
good question i think
and then one could try also to ask the
same question about classical
information equal clonable information
in a more restricted theories because
what i'm discussing how now is just in
the theory in which those exotic sources
should be understood as the most
powerful source i can imagine just
restricted by causality and
device replication but i could also
consider more restricted source and is
this still valid
so actually
there there is another paper which show
with which has shown that classical
equal clonable it's just uh miguel and
ellie paper about
the convergence of inflation because
so now you take this triangle and you
take these variables to be classical
what ellie and miguel have proven is
that if you consider all the fan out
inflation so looking like this kind of
inflection larger and larger you do have
convergence so if you define your
probability distribution with the
integral formula in this network it's
equal to all the probability
distributions which are compatible with
all the imaginable
inflation so it really means that
classical information equal clonable
information when you only consider
classical information
okay and then another direction i see
which is completely connected to what
miriam told this morning is that
we could try also to start with this
work and extend it to try to reconstruct
quantum information theory from its
correlations
so if you look at bell theorem it
excludes a local hidden variable model
so we know that there is a concrete
quantum experiment the chsh which
excludes a classical information theory
to explain uh like probability
distribution
and then what i have just done is to
exclude all the theory which are based
on generalized bipartite and argument
only there is a concrete experiment with
the g8 state which cannot be explained
with this theory so it's what i have uh
said during my talk
and then so as merian told us there is
also a very concrete quantum experiment
we can reject
real number quantum theory and there are
other generalized probabilistic theories
which can be excluded by very concrete
quantum experiment
so actually a good question is is this
list complete i guess not right so
couldn't we try to exclude
more alternative theories to explain
quantum correlations in some very
specific causal structure
and could we
be able eventually to be able to
characterize quantum information theory
from its correlation so the goal would
be to have a set of different very
concrete setups
associated to the probability
distribution we can compute with a
standard quantum information theory and
say that actually quantum information
theory is the unique theory which is
able to explain all those uh potent all
those experimental results so i think
it's really a very important goal it
would be a generalization of bell
theorem which is very powerful because
now
we don't only
reject some theories we certify the
theory
as the unique one which can be used to
explain uh what we see and
yeah i think it would be very important
and fundamental to understand what
quantum
information theory is or is not and
maybe also very important to understand
quantum information theory in the
context in which we are not
so sure that it holds still so with the
the problem of gravitation like
reconciling it with the gravitation so
maybe trying to do these experiments
with black holes or try to understand
what it would give with black holes to
try to understand if quantum mechanics
is still valid in that case
okay so i'm done so with this i want to
thank you my uh thanks my two colleagues
savvy and ellie
i'm happy to answer two questions
any questions
it's really interesting talk so
do you have a kind of sense of how you
would know that there's no other theory
that could explain
the set of correlations because it seems
like that's
i i think it's a very difficult goal
yes
uh so actually
um
there is a huge difference between uh
the the work i just presented here and
and this work for instance because here
uh you see that i was really uh
i i didn't say what my theory was right
i just gave axioms very
high level axiom which should be
satisfied by the theory whereas in this
work what we did was really to take a
very concrete theory and rule it out so
there is first this right so do you want
to take concrete theories and rule out
rule them out one by one or you want to
take class of theories satisfying some
axioms and
and uh
yeah no so i i think it's a very
difficult question also because if you
want to do it in this kind of
way of thinking in which you just give
very broad axiom which should be
satisfied by the theory
then there is no reason why you should
obtain the formalism of quantum
information theory which is based on
hilbert spaces density matrices povm
elements so okay even if you don't know
what it is it's the very concrete
mathematical formalism there are many
many very concrete mathematical
formalism which have nothing to do with
these hilbert space so i can go to
bohmian mechanics or i can go to vigner
formalism or i can go to many other
formalism they are all completely
equivalent to quantum mechanics but they
use completely different mathematical
objects
so if you want to do such a proof and
completely characterize in the end there
is no reason why you should find the
hilbert space formalism because as
regards only the probability
distribution there is no difference
between the hilbert's phase formalism
and vigner formalism for instance so
this is also a very hard question i
guess how to
manage all these parallel formalism
which have nothing to do one with each
other
this is a question maybe
not so directly related to your talk but
but maybe when you're thinking about the
the general other possible theories so
in in all of these things you have your
diagrams with the edges pointing in a
certain direction but i mean the talk
the last talk that we saw this morning
was sort of suggesting that maybe in
quantum states
it's not so clear whether or not you
know
that that could be
subject to
quantum
randomness so i don't know have you
thought about that yes so actually it's
a very good question because i was
discussing this this morning and i tried
a bit so
let me take this triangle for instance
okay
what about uh
cyclic causal structure right so what
would happen if now i have a b c and a
is the cause of b which is the cause of
c which is the cause of a some like
stuff like this
can i still try to do inflation after
all i have grass right so i could try to
inflate it
so i think that there is a very
problematic a very deep problem behind
this which is that
when you look at dag it's very safe if
you look at your dag and all your
transfer functions so i will just talk
about classical theory for simplicity if
all your transfer function makes sense
locally
then the global
experiment the global protocol will make
sense but now if i have some loop it's
not true it can make sense locally but i
can have a grandfather paradox for
instance or a creation of information
paradox
globally so i need to enforce by hand a
global
compatibility condition and inflation is
i think not capturing this so actually
it's not completely true i know that
computer scientists have been using
inflation in the
byzantine agreement problem
so
okay the byzantine agreement problem is
just you have three parties a b c
and they receive some inputs and they
have to do some tasks and give some
output right and they have access to
unbounded uh
like uh communication they are able to
communicate as much as they want right
but what is very important in
in this protocol is that there is one
traitor somewhere so one is not
behaving well right
and then the goal is to show that there
is a task they cannot succeed in without
going into the details and the proof is
saying imagine that they have a protocol
for this task then perform some
inflation so now you will have a b c a
prime
b prime c prime and they communicate
exactly the same
okay
and then uh they are able to find some
incompatibility by looking at this but
this is very tricky because
uh when you do inflation what is really
important is that all the boxes should
not be able to tell whether they are in
the inflated
graph or in the original graph because
if they were able to tell the difference
they would adopt a different strategy
and you will not be able to make any
deduction
and if they were all trusted a strategy
to detect in which graph they are would
be just to for alice to take a random
variable to send it to bob and ask him
to do plus one and bob does the same and
alice
gets the new variable and see that it's
x plus three or x plus six right and
then she would detect in which network
she is so here it's working because
there is someone not trusted somewhere
which can completely uh kill this kind
of strategy
so you
it's not true that you cannot do
inflation in uh like
non-tag
structure
but there is a very deep problem which
is that they will be able to detect in
which
if they are in the inflated or not
except if you have extra assumptions
like this for instance or it's very
tricky
so just on the very last slide you
mentioned bohmian mechanics
and so on i just want to understand how
you're using terminology
um there's a way of using terminology so
that say everett and and and boom and a
non-local
theory like boom are different theories
right i mean there's a way of
understanding what a theory is such as
those presenting you different accounts
of the world
but generally it's thought there's no
empirical way to distinguish those
yes so when you said from the
correlations i can somehow nail down a
theory
what exactly yes yes so
it's it's a good question
it was somehow the problem i gave at the
end right what
so okay i i pretended that i had a very
clear question in mind but it's not true
actually and
this is part of the
vague
question right so being able to to well
pose the question is already
quite a problem
speaker
[Music]
and we will take a 10-minute break